نقلت رويتر مسؤولين امريكيين انه من
المرجح ان تكون روسيا او عناصر مواليه لها
وراء تسريب وثائقه سريه من البنتاجون
ويبدو انها توضح بالتفصيل القدرات
القتاليه لاوكرانيا ونقاط الضعف المحتمله
وجود الناتو الواسعه للمساعده في صد الغزو
الروسي من جههها اعلنت وزاره العدل
الامريكيه في بيان فتح تحقيق في الامر
وكانت يوميه نيويورك تايمز افادت بان
مجموعه من الوثائق يعتقد انها
تفصل اسرارا من الامن القوميه الامريكي
بدات في الظهور على مواقع للتواصل
الاجتماعي واوضحت الصحيفه نقلا عن مسئولين
امريكيين ان عددا مستندات يفوق المئه
والصفه مصادره الجريده التسريب بانه كابوس
لكل من الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
واستراليا وكذلك نيوزيلندا وكندا التي
تتبادل المعلومات الاستخباراتيه ونقلت
الصحيفه عن مسؤول سابق في البنتاجون قوله
ان التسريب يبدو عملا متعمدا الاضرار
بجهود اوكرانيا والولايات المتحده وحلف
الشمال الاطلسي